-Welcome to the Launch Zone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
Yes. That's right.
-Wow.
-For this game, we're gonna
play you a popular song.
When you think you know it,
stomp on your foot pedal
to launch the mic
in the air like this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you catch the mic correctly
and name that song,
your team gets 1,000 points.
But if you drop the mic
or get it wrong,
someone else can buzz in.
Round 1 is called
"Classroom Instruments."
The band will play a popular
song on toy instruments
When you think you know it,
get ready to launch that mic.
Here's the first song.
-1, 2, 3.
♪♪
-Oh, uh...
-"STAY."
-Yes, that's correct.
By Kid LAROI.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God!
-That was fantastic.
You nailed it.
-Julia probably wrote
all these songs.
-I know. That's not fair.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's not true.
-Dang.
-Alright.
Get ready for another one.
Here we go.
♪♪
[ Audience cheering ]
-♪ Heal me up,
buttercup, baby ♪
♪ Won't you let me down? ♪
-Yeah. Alright.
Judges, we're gonna give it.
It's "Build Me Up,"
but that's good.
♪ Build me up, build me up ♪
-Love you.
-That's exactly right.
-It's for a good cause, Jimmy.
-♪ I love you still ♪
♪ I need you ♪
-♪ I need you ♪
-♪ More than anyone, darling ♪
♪ Know that I have
from the start ♪
♪ So build me up, buttercup,
and don't break my heart ♪
Very nice right there.
-Whoo!
-Don't break it.
-Don't break that heart.
-That's the way to do it.
1,000 points.
-Alright. Let's hear
the final song for this round.
It's a tied game right now.
-2, 3, 4.
♪♪
-♪ Ah, na, na, na,
na, na, na, na, na ♪
♪♪
-Go. Let's go!
-♪ I can't feel my face ♪
-That's exactly right.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Correct. Wow.
You pulled that one out.
♪♪
-Whoo!
-That's The Weeknd right there.
Alright. This is a close game.
Here we go.
This is round 2.
This is called
"Instant Classical," okay?
-Oh, I'm gonna get this one.
-Our deejay --
Yeah. You are, J.D.
[ Laughter ]
You have an advantage here.
Our deejay is gonna play
a popular song
in the style of classical music.
You will have to buzz in
and tell me the title.
Here is our first song.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoa!
-"No scrubs"?
-Yes! That is correct!
-What were you doing?!
I-I was making sure.
-And the catch.
-Yes.
-Oh, my God. Julia Michaels.
-Yeah.
-She's like what an end zone?
Nice job. That was it.
Let's hear another one.
Here we go.
♪♪
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Dynamite."
-That is correct!
-Whoo!
-Come on, now.
That's exactly right.
-Thanks, Jimmy.
-[ Vocalizes ]
♪ Like dynamite ♪
Okay. Here we go.
-Ah!
-The last one for this round.
What a game, what a game.
♪♪
-Oh.
"Eye of the Tiger"?
-Yes! Correct!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is how you do it.
-I got nothing.
-Jimmy,
play a Jason Derulo song.
-No! Come on, he got enough.
-Come on, Jason.
-I might even get that one.
I ain't gonna lie.
[ Laughter ]
-It is time for the final round
of this challenge.
This is called
"One Second Wonders."
We're only gonna play you
one second of a song.
[ Audience murmuring ]
-This is my round right here.
-There are no Jason Derulo songs
on this.
[ Laughter ]
Just let you know right now.
Alright. Ready for this?
Let's hear the first track,
one second.
-♪ You ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, Jason.
Come on, Jason. Come on.
-I know this one.
-Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
-"Crank That (Soulja Boy)."
-Oh!
That's exactly right.
-♪ Watch me crank it,
watch me roll ♪
-That's how you do it
right there.
They got one.
That's how you do it
right there.
-That was a master catch.
-"Crank That (Soulja Boy)."
Good job, Jason.
Alright. Let's hear
another one-second song.
-♪ Ahh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, the grab!
-Yes!
-"Baby," Justin Bieber.
-That is exactly correct.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What a catch.
-Oh, my God!
-♪ Baby, baby, ohh ♪
♪ Baby, baby ♪
-Love that.
That was a nice catch, as well.
Alright. Here we go.
Last one for this round.
Here we go.
♪♪
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, hey.
-Yes!
Whoa!
-"I Gotta Feeling."
-Oh! That's it right there.
-I had the same feeling.
I had the same feeling.
-That's 5,000 points
for that one.
-I had the same feeling.